الهيئه العليا للانتخابات قالت انها
اجتمعت وقررت احتساب الاصوات التي ستاتي
الى المرشح المنسحب محرم انجا لان انسحابه
جاء بعد نشر القوائم النهائيه للمرشحين في
الجريده الرسميه بحسب الماده الثانيه عشره
من قانون الانتخابات لن يكون انسحاب محرم
انجاساريا الا اذا ذهبت الانتخابات الى
جوله ثانيه في هذا الاطار محرم انجاي يفجر
مفاجاه ويدعو انصاره بشكل غير مباشر
للتصويت الى الرئيس التركي رجل طيب
اردوغان ان جاء قال في تغريده يوم السبت
لا تجعلوا انصار فتح الله
سعداء وهذا يؤدي او هذا يعطي انصاره خيط
الطريق للتصفيق للرئيس التركي كون كونه
المح بشكل غير مباشر واتهامات سابقه لانجا
بدعم فتح الله او تنظيف فتح وحزب العمال
الكردستاني مرشحة
مرشح
كمال